réjean l'abbé vient tout juste de
rencontrer son oncologue il a appris
qu'il devrait subir des traitements de
radiothérapie à gatineau à 600
kilomètres de chez lui on a vécu pendant
deux ans que la famille on n'a pas pu
les voir où j'ai quatre enfants les
petits enfants sept petits-enfants
on aime sony voir on pouvait pour
l'heure en plus haut lieu de traiter ici
ah ouais on a écrêté à gatineau
pourtant tout est en place au centre de
radio oncologie régional de rouyn
noranda les chaises sont installées à
l'accueil le scan est prêt à recevoir
les patients et le déménagement des
salles de chimiothérapie et complétée
mais il n'y a toujours pas de
traitements de radiothérapie parce qu'il
manque au moins un technologue en radio
oncologie pour pouvoir démarrer les
services si on aurait pu là bas on le
refuse c'est ce qui aurait été
souhaitable
par contre je peux dire on n'a rien à se
reprocher en douce et au niveau des îles
stratégiques des efforts continus de
l'avant pour faire en sorte qu'on puisse
avoir les ressources nécessaires dans
les inrocks
pour la pts le syndicat qui représente
entre autres les technologues cette
situation est une preuve de plus que
l'abitibi-témiscamingue doit avoir accès
à des primes supplémentaires du
ministère de la santé pourrait être plus
attractive au niveau de recrutement
c'est très difficile là on a seulement 2
ou r2 cégep
à la grandeur du québec qui offrent le
programme en français c'est pas beaucoup
de technologues qui graduent donc pour
la région ici ce serait essentiel
d'avoir un atout supplémentaire pour
pouvoir attirer ces gens dans notre
région c'est pour ça que la pts demande
également de un statut particulier pour
la région de l'abitibi témiscamingue on
voit vraiment les eaux on voit encore
pendant ce temps l'équipe qui travaille
depuis trois ans sur la mise en place du
centre de radio oncologie régional a
elle aussi hâte de recevoir ses premiers
patients je me souviens c'était la
première visite en 2018 était 2018 avec
la famille quand ils ont commencé à
parler du projet donc c'était un rêve
c'était un rêve pour moi pour ma famille
et pour la population si c'est vraiment
c'est quelque chose c'est une expérience
très riche c'est tellement un grand
accomplissement dans une vie
professionnelle que de pouvoir ouvrir ce
service le à la population que je suis
vraiment à chier les efforts de
recrutement se poursuivre au 6 de
l'abitibi témiscamingue on espère être
en mesure de donner les traitements de
radiothérapie que je reprochais ici
annie-claude l'une au raid au canada
rouyn noranda